madeleine sébastien chers collègues
bonsoir moi j'aime bien le mot nude du
du panel de ce soir c'est un plus à mi
chemin entre la rétrospective et la
prospective au revient sur la semaine
non je croisais aussi sur l'avenir est
quand même assez immédiat puisque notre
jeu disons le le calendrier se précise à
ottawa notamment il ya le conseil des
ministres on le sait le madania plus
d'autres 25-26 on ne savait pas trop
fière c'est le 26 retour en chambre le
22 un mois plus tard qu'est ce que vous
retenez de ce calendrier parce qu'il ya
eu des critiques aujourd'hui oui des
critiques un peu justifiée je vous
dirais parce que c'est assez long quand
même alexis pour former ce cabinet là ça
va prendre environ cinq semaines un peu
plus que 5 semaines et dans l'histoire
récente c'est quand même long
justin trudeau lors de la dernière
élection avait mis un mois à former son
cabinet mary jeu mais même ce n'était
pas tout à fait traditionnelle alors du
premier mandat de justin trudeau c'est
libye il y avait fallu deux semaines a
formé son cabinet deux semaines et demie
plus tôt et sous stephen harper tous les
cabinets avaient été formés en deux
semaines deux semaines et demie donc là
on parle du double du temps alors que
justin trudeau avait dit en campagne on
est à la croisée des chemins on est à un
moment charnière
il faut vraiment prendre des décisions
pour en finir avec la coved 19 donc ça
donnait l'impression d'un gouvernement
qui était pressé de prendre des
décisions alors que là ça prend quand
même plusieurs semaines avant de
recommencer à siéger ça veut dire aussi
probablement et des comités
parlementaires qui seront pas formé
avant l'année prochaine donc je peux
comprendre l'opposition d'être déçu de
ne pas pouvoir siéger plus tôt ce matin
la cohérence en politique c'est très
important avion avec nos politiciens
soient cohérents ici un manque de
cohérence et à dire que comme madeleine
l'adie avait une espèce d'urgence en
campagne égal à
avoir un nouveau gouvernement piloté
comme si l'urgence a disparu pour quoi
bon ces intrigues pourquoi on épaules on
n'est pas en coulisses mais qu'est ce
qu'on peut déduire de tout ça voyez un
libéral qui m'a dit on attendait que
pascal saintonge dans brome missisquoi
soit officiellement élu s'est produit au
milieu de la semaine je me rappelle plus
quelle journée mardi ou mercredi
peut-être
parce que elle va accéder au conseil des
ministres selon ce qu'on comprendra
environ quand le conseil des ministres
sera formé puis à partir d'elles bas il
y avait peut-être un jeu de chaises
musicales qui pouvaient ou au jeu d'un
effet domino qui pouvait être entraînés
en même temps ça l'aurait pas empêché de
faire son conseil des ministres la
semaine prochaine pourquoi attendre une
semaine de plus est ce que c'est parce
que il travaille sur quelque chose
d'exceptionnel donc il est très
concentré sur son travail pour offrir un
nouveau discours aux canadiennes
on espère d'une certaine façon que il a
utilisé ces semaines a pour nous
présenter quelque chose de constructif
et réfléchi sur le pourquoi madeleine ou
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres choses qui vous
viennent à l'esprit
je vais pas nécessairement justifier une
décision que je ne partage pas
nécessairement comme je vous dis je
trouve que c'est long mais la semaine
prochaine la gouverneure générale est en
mission en allemagne donc lorsqu'elle
n'est pas là c'est sûr que c'est plus
continuer d'assermenter un cabinet mais
en même temps justin trudeau un petit
mot à dire sur les déplacements de la
gouverneure générale s'est pas elle même
qui décide de partir en mission il peut
y avoir quand même des fois des demandes
qui sont faites et j'ai bien
l'impression que s'il avait fallu qu'il
reste au pays elle serait restée au pays
mais marie messier mais il ya aussi eu
toute la question de la chine avec les
deux michael sahara occupé du temps du
gouvernement depuis les élections là
lundi justin trudeau va se rendre dans
la nation tout près de câbles ou que
vous savez celle où on a découvert des
tombes adjani près d'un ancien
pensionnat autochtone donc encore une
fois le justin trudeau est en mode on
répare les pots cassés lundi prochain
donc il a des dossiers dans son assiette
mais là aussi des dossiers très urgent à
régler ou pressant du moins quand on
parle par exemple quand on pense par
exemple justement quelle quelle approche
adoptée il avait lâché 2 mai les deux
michael ont été ont été libérés le
dossier de la réponse est d'ailleurs
réconciliation c'est en est un qui
pressent donc il faut qu'ils gouvernent
pour ça il faut qu'il soit au parlement
il faut qu'ils soient redevables face à
la population en tout en tout respect
pour le gouverneur général et ses
fonctions je pas sûr que quelqu'un
horaires vraiment remarqué s'il avait
annulé son voyage la semaine prochaine
elle aurait pu se faire dire de rester
au pays mais il a fait le choix de ne
pas le faire de ne pas prendre cette
décision les décisions qui sont
peut-être aussi difficile pour lui il
faut respecter la parité la
représentation régionale
il ya eu du mouvement ait eu des départs
en amont de cette campagne électorale ça
fait partie aussi peut-être des
nombreuses explications non deux ça fait
partie c'est certain du casse tête de
justin trudeau parce qu'il s'est fixé
comme règle d'avoir un pas cabinet
paritaire et lors de la campagne
électorale il ya trois ministres femmes
qui ont été défaites dans les élections
et avait en plus catherine mais cana
l'ancien ministre aux enfants aux
infrastructures que décidé de ne pas se
représenter
donc il fallait qu'ils comptent quatre
postes de femmes alors qu'il ya de la
représentation régionale qui va pouvoir
s'opérer mais ici comme si ce facteur
femmes mais ce facteur et
représentations régionales ne
s'imbriquent pas bien regardé en alberta
il compte maintenant deux députés ça
c'est nouveau mais ce sont deux hommes
en nouvelle écosse là où bernadette
gordon la ministre de la dépêche a été
défaite il ya plusieurs hommes une femme
donc parfois le choix devient plus
difficile mais cependant combien nuit on
doit dormir là dessus un moment donné la
nature
la décision doit se prendre c'est sûr
que c'est un casse tête et c'est
toujours en cavale et tout ce que de
former un cabinet il ya trois 3 4 deux
députés qui sont heureux de faire partie
du cabinet et on a bien plus qu'ils sont
déçus de rester sur les bancs est
aribert n'importe quel premier ministre
qui est passé par cet exercice là vous à
vous dire que c'est un des exercices les
plus difficiles d'abord trois quarts du
caucus pense que il al'étoffe pour être
ministre ce qui est pas le cas et ce qui
était ministre dans l'ancien cabinet
pense qu'ils ont un ticket gratuit pour
accéder au nouveau cabinet on leur doit
quelque chose d'une certaine façon donc
ça complique les choses dit oui des
questions deux hommes partis en famille
des questions de représenter représente
représentation voilà je vais finir par
dire régionales et
il ya des amitiés aussi là dedans en
passant de la compétence aussi en
principe doit rentrer comme critère pour
accéder au conseil des ministres donc
c'est très complexe et très complexe et
on pourrait épiloguer encore longtemps
steven guilbeault et torres mais il faut
se garder des munitions pour les
semaines qui s'en viennent un petit tour
de table rapide ça c'est un fait
intéressant quand même le nombre de
sièges à la chambre des communes va
passer de 338 à 342 dès 2024 parce qu'on
renouvelle sa tous les dix ans ou à peu
près or le québec est la seule province
à perdre un siège dans tout ce
redécoupage fédéral petit tour rapide
là-dessus madeleine pour le moment c'est
un calcul qui est très mathématique en
voie parce qu'il faut considérer les
changements démographiques essayer de se
mettre le plus représentatif des
changements démographiques et la
population du québec croit moins
rapidement que celles du reste du canada
donc c'est ce qui se reflète là dedans
mais c'est quand même probablement
peu c'est remarquable 2 parce que ça
fait depuis
1966 que c'est pas arrivé qu'une
province perdre comme ça un siège il ya
eu des règles de droit acquis qui ont
été ajoutés aux règles de calcul parfois
ça a permis à des provinces de conserver
des sièges qu'elle n'aurait peut-être
pas conserver autrement donc c'est que
c'est un siège mais le poids du québec à
la chambre des communes même lorsqu'elle
naît lorsque la province ne perd pas de
siège diminue peu à peu un petit mot
historique il ya une trentaine d'années
c'était l'accord de charlton qui
était adoptée et dans l'accord de
charlottetown on prévoyait que le poids
du québec à la chambre des communes
serait d'au moins 25% et là si je ne
m'abuse on est rendu à 20 une bonne
quelques % mais moins que 25 donc voyez
vous le poids que continue de diminuer
progressivement à la chambre des
communes et d'un point de vue québec
chaque fois que le pouvoir l'influencé
du québec diminuer la chambre des
communes c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour le québec en particulier quand on
opère en plus quand on perd une
circonscription donc ça c'est d'un point
de vue québec une mauvaise nouvelle d'un
point de vue très personnel c'est un
défi nouveau pour apprendre à situer
quatre nouvelles circonscriptions sur la
carte électorale pour les élections
cette nouvelle pour vous c'est bastié
parce que c'est un redécoupage
c'est possible que d'autres
circonscriptions change de frontières et
change de nom alors je me suis tellement
donné pour la dernière pour le citoyen
oui mais c'est ça ce n'est une expertise
toujours à renouveler sa révolution mais
vous le faites si bien vous le faites si
bien et ça peut être allongée quelques
noms de circonscription aussi que vous
en raffolez de ces
interminables mais poursuivant avec vous
à sébastien parce qu'il ya aussi et
quand je dis qu'on se projette vers
l'avenir immédiat discours inaugural à
québec marty a beaucoup de choses à dire
à ce sujet oui la première chose à dire
c'est que depuis mercredi à 16h
officiellement la session parlementaire
à québec est prorogée sauf que c'est par
ici complètement sous le radar cette
semaine à cause de toutes sortes
d'autres choses notamment la vaccination
obligatoire donc ça a été officialisée
mercredi à 16 heures et mardi vers 14
heures monsieur legault va se lever en
chambre pour livrer ce discours
d'ouverture donc essentiellement il veut
repartir sur de nouvelles bases de
données les priorités du gouvernement
pour cette année électorale qu'est ce
qu'on va surveiller on va surveiller la
santé oms veut un peu mettre au pas
peut-être giacomo même être ou pas les
médecins omnipraticiens on trouve qu'ils
prennent pas assez en charge de patients
il ya trop de patients orphelins au
québec en ce moment on veut s'assurer
que ça fonctionne dans les cpe le
ministre m'a tuer la combinaison de la
famille va présenter un projet nous pour
réformer un peu la façon dont on fait
les choses dans les centres de la petite
enfance on veut régler aussi la
négociation avec les éducatrices et
l'environnement ça pourrait être un
enjeu important de la prochaine année il
ira d'ailleurs à la coop la conférence
des nations unies sur les changements
climatiques à la au début du mois de
novembre oui où on lui posera sûrement
des questions la band écosse sur le
troisième ligne 1 on verra bien
madeleine un mot aussi sur saucisse est
à noter sa part un peu aussi sous le
radar mais c'est important de le
rappeler l'alberta tient référendum sur
la péréquation ledit prochain
l'alberta tient deux références ces
changements car aussi y en a sur la
changement d'heure donc on va demander à
la population albertaine celle veut
conserver l'heure d'été à l'année mais
l'autre question est pas mal plus
compliqué pour jason kenny jason kenny
voulait créer un rapport de force en
demandant si la population voulait qu'on
retire le principe de péréquation de la
constitution évidemment jason kenny
savez très bien que même si la majorité
de la population était en faveur de
cette idée là de retirer la péréquation
ça serait pas automatiquement il
faudrait négocier donc ils essayaient
d'avoir un rapport de force pour
négocier le problème de jason kenny non
seulement on sait pas qu'on qui va voter
en faveur de son et de son idée mais
même s'ils avaient une majorité de gens
qu'ils appuyaient l'appuyer dans son
projet monsieur kenny est tellement peu
populaire en ce moment que ce serait
très difficile pour lui de faire un coup
de force constitutionnel essayer de
rallier les provinces nécessaire pour
changer changer cette péréquation là où
pays alors qu'il y en a qui en reçoivent
de la péréquation je pense au québec par
exemple ça me surprendrait que françois
legault disons bien eu bien sûr monsieur
kelly on est d'accord avec vous on va on
veut sacrifier des milliards de dollars
j'en doute beaucoup c'est comme un
référendum sur che ce week-end est aussi
parce qu'il est tellement peu populaire
sur son idée de réforme et la
péréquation va être soumise à référendum
ce sera intéressant à voir le résultat
parce que si c'est très faible en appui
à sa proposition on pourra peut-être
aussi l'interpréter comme un désaveu de
la part des albertains face à jason
kenney qui est qui qui qui est dans le
trouble en fait sa bouille dans son
caucus la gestion de la pandémie a très
mal été pour jason kenney il a été mou
sur les mesures sanitaires il ya bien
des gens qui lui en veulent donc il ya
eu un petit danger dans ce référendum en
tout cas pour le signal politique que ça
envoie de l'apport des albertains voilà
monsieur kenny qui avait conçu imaginé
ce référendum avant une certaine
pandémie il était capitaine canada il
avait toi le montant de la politique
canadienne lille et on a l'impression
que c'est l'étoile fils on a le sens de
la formule de sébastien bovet légendaire
alors en terminant aussi un petit mot
madeleine justin trudeau sera un câble
ou ça serait surveillé la semaine
prochaine oui je le disais il ya un
instant pour réparer les pots cassés et
quand on répare des pots cassés parfois
il faut mettre de la colle je sais
trudeau pourra difficilement arrivé
là-bas les mains v de la communauté
certains à des actions concrètes dont
l'impression que il veut surtout pas que
ça serve d'événements médiatiques pour
effacer son faux pas donc on verra ce
qu'il va faire lundi je ne le sais pas
encore mais je m'attends quand même à ce
que la communauté s'attendent des
actions et on n'a pas vu souvent au
cours des dernières semaines
alors vous on vous a vu souvent cette
semaine ça va se poursuivre la semaine
prochaine mais entre les deux une fête
semaine et je vous souhaite un bon repos
chers collègues parfois merci bon
endroit pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
m